this is
the ramsey show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about life
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
anthony o'neal
and we are with you this hour it is a
free phone call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight
eight two five five two two five if
we're talking life
that means we're gonna talk about money
and thankfully my colleague anthony's
here
to answer those questions we'll talk
about your work
because that income thing doesn't have
to be
so miserable you can actually ao love
what you do
and make the money you need
we'll talk some relationships we'll talk
whatever you need to talk about that is
eating at you today we are here we enjoy
coaching people up
and we are here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two
five hey yo i'm coming off of uh well
the digital live stream event
the get hired event a lot of people out
there looking to level up
yeah to to to keep on moving and uh
and a lot of people getting serious yeah
uh coming out of
covid coming out of the pandemic they're
getting serious about taking
uh their money game to the next level as
well and you know
there is there's no separating your work
and your money i mean
they're just tied together and
you have seen in your own journey as
well as in the lives of so many that
you've coached
uh there's something to getting on
purpose in your money and your work yeah
absolutely
you know um ken one of the things i i've
noticed and i want to thank you for your
your digital event because
i had a lot of my young people sign up
oh thank you so we pushed it on my
platform and i'm telling you the
testimonies that are coming from this
event were just phenomenal you really
helped them understand their purpose
and i feel i feel sorry for some people
in the world because some some people
actually lost some employees because of
your event
loss of employees but then some gain
some better qualified
employees because they landed in their
sweet spot and that's my thing when you
can go to work every single day
and at least be happy and passionate
about what you're doing
then the next phase of your life on
building debt i mean building wealth
getting out of debt
is even easier because now you can
really focus on that
absolutely right so i love that we are
here for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's start it off ao
in los angeles california where mike
joins us mike how can we help
hey guys uh i had a question um i'm 21
i live with my parents um my income
varies greatly every month but i have
about a hundred thousand
saved up i'm wondering
what the best move is what how big of a
condo our house is
is too big with the size what a down
payment should be and
do i buy it and pay it off am i buying
it
and renting it out for another year
what's the smartest move mike where did
you uh get this hundred thousand dollars
from
uh i am a freelance uh production
assistant and
obviously i have no expenses living with
my parents so the last
uh two and a half years i've been able
to to save that up
so so this is nine inheritance your
parents didn't give you this money
you've been working the last four years
and just living
way way way way below your means and
just putting this money into the savings
correct
correct yeah cool so on a worst case
scenario how much money do you think you
can make
a month uh worst case
yes 2500 2500 in la which is not a lot
of money
okay what is your best case scenario
um 13 000. 13 000. which
in california that's good money for a 21
year old
uh what are you averaging right now
uh four grand okay four grand
cool beans so and let me ask you this
question
um no school right you're not in school
currently correct no correct okay cool
uh so i'm gonna let ken talk to the the
career side of things
uh on the money side of things um
a hundred thousand dollars in your
savings account is great okay
um you don't need that for three months
i would definitely say in in california
i'm from oceanside california
so i know exactly where you are in la
area you're gonna need
for a rough case scenario you need about
at least 20 grand
in your savings account for three to six
months
and so that means you have about 80
grand that you can live off of so
i'm not going to suggest that you go pay
cash
for a home i'm i'm going to say
go rent something until you can get a
solid
consistent income coming in of at least
at least in california five to eight
grand for your age
so that way you have a comfortable
lifestyle uh but i'm not going to say go
buy an apartment go buy a condo
i'm saying go rent something get out
there on your own
get that up underneath your belt for at
least a year time time frame
and can and you can walk through how to
get your income
to be a solid at least five to eight
grand a month guaranteed every month
bare minimum then after that yeah man go
purchase something
and keep working and eventually pay it
off early but
i do think that you should be moving out
of your parents house here relatively
soon if not this year
january of next year you should have a
game plan on how you get out on your own
yeah mike my question is uh is it tough
for you to get a second job
uh due to the nature of the production
schedule where you kind of have to be on
call and i may be assuming that but i'm
curious
no that's completely correct yeah well
listen you've done a great job i think
ao's right i
you know are you feeling like you can't
afford to get a roommate at least
uh rent for a while are you are you just
scared of it or you've run the numbers
you don't feel like you can do that
um i'm just something i'm not really
comfortable with
and i feel like i'd rather uh you know
save up with no expenses that my parents
can have
and have a roommate at the moment good i
mean i gotta tell you i mean i
aio you 10 you and dave tend to be more
on get out of the parents house
my position on living with parents is if
if there's no boundary issues there
and there there isn't something that's
kind of making you feel less than or
whatever
and this is a strategic money play
because it's los angeles because of that
i'm actually okay with you're getting
with it but i acknowledge that
if dave we're here he's gonna say what
you said get out of there soon
uh you're 21 you got a strategy here i
would be trying to work as much as you
could
outside of the production stuff that's
the only thing i'd add i know you've
gotta
leave yourself open but i would keep
socking money away
and i would get to a point in your head
where it's not emotional where it's okay
this is logical i
actually can afford to rent and get an
apartment and get a roommate or
something i do think you have to get
there
i'm not saying it's got to be right away
but make sure this is an emotional thing
ao is what i'm saying like
you may be uncomfortable with it but so
what you talk about this all the time
you tell young people what do you tell
them about being uncomfortable man don't
allow your comfort zone to become your
kill zone
you know and so i i believe that he
should step outside of his comfort zone
but i also want to echo what you're
saying ken is you know
if he loans he has a strategic plan yes
and he's working that plan
and we see fruit of that plan uh moving
forward
then absolutely stay there another year
i don't have a problem with that
i think dave and i have a problem when
we have a lazy man
or even a lazy woman and i agree with
that at home there's no plan
there's nothing strategic there's no
goals they're just
comfortable and they're killing their
own future and parents are killing their
future
because they're not aiming towards
something and we're seeing
fruit from their labor so i agree with
you in that part bro yeah no
good advice there's a sharp young man i
love that he saved up that kind of money
yeah and great advice on he's got his
emergency fund
i like to keep stacking yeah if he's
single ladies go get him
there you go you knew it was coming ao
he's got the
full circle advice there for our man
mike in los angeles all right
don't go anywhere we got more of your
calls coming up
he's anthony o'neil i'm ken coleman this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
anthony o'neal and we're taking your
questions about life
you got your money questions ao's got
you you want to talk about your work
how you may want to get promoted make
more money maybe you're not happy in
your work
maybe you're trying to figure out what
it is you're supposed to do so if you
want to go from paycheck to purpose
i'll talk to you about that as well but
we are here for you whatever your
question
it is a free phone call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five there are a ton of
underrated holidays and this is one of
my favorites may
2nd coming up it's going to be national
life insurance day
it may not sound like the most fun but
it is important life insurance protects
your family financially when you pass
away
so they're not going to deal with money
stress on top of losing you
now you need the right kind of life
insurance the only kind we recommend
here at ramsey solutions is term life
insurance
that's worth at least 10 to 12 times
your income
our free coverage checkup tool will help
you find the right term life policy
plus other types of insurance you do and
don't need to protect you
and your family to get your results text
checkup to 33789 that's check
up to 33789 to find the best coverage
for you all right back to the phones we
go
toledo ohio is where kyle joins us kyle
how can we help
hi i'm 24 years old i'm graduating from
college in a couple weeks
and i have about forty thousand dollars
to up and i have a salary job that i'm
working
um make seventy thousand dollars a year
um i have no student debt and my car's
paid off
so i'm just trying to figure out how i
can best um
like raise my credit score i have a 715
right now and i'm just trying to get my
credit up so i can uh get a loan for a
house
hmm interesting wow way to go kyle
you're off and running buddy yeah man
what do you do for a living i'm real
curious yeah so
um i do supply chain for a major
corporation in the area
wow and ao's gonna jump in on that
financial question but i'm just curious
to ask one more thing here
what do you think your upward mobility
looks like making 70
000 a year you're in supply chain what
do you think uh the next couple years
looks like for you professionally
financially yeah um so i i have a really
good job right now for
the next two or three years and then
after that i'll be making about 90 or
95.
all right that's all i wanted and then
that's pretty good young man yeah
i'm proud of you man how old are you
again bro i missed it when you first
said it um
i'm i'm 24. 24. okay cool great are you
living at home with your parents are you
out on your own
um nope my apartment okay cool great man
so let me ask you this question because
you said something about you you got a
715 credit score you want to raise it up
a little bit more
why like why why do you care about a
credit score
yeah so i'm just worried because i mean
i've never had to have a loan for like a
car or steam loans or anything
that i don't show like i i that i
said that i might not be like lendable
essentially like yeah i have 40 000 now
but like i don't show history of like
hey
we've lent you money and you can trust
that you'll pay it back
essentially so no histories i don't have
a credit card you only have a credit
card
yes okay what's on it right now how much
do you owe in a credit card
um so it has a 600 max i usually put
like 200
on a month okay and then i guess you
just paid off right
yeah okay cool great um so here here's
my thought process and i really want to
help you all
walk through this and this is what i
hear from a lot of people especially
people in their 20s and in their 30s
like anthony i'm so scared to not have a
credit score because i will not be able
to purchase a home i have
no history showing if i do not have a
credit score i have no history showing
that i can pay my bills on time and that
is a lie
okay that's a lie okay uh you're paying
your bills on time with your rent
uh you're paying your bills on time with
your phone bill your cell phone bill
that you're calling in on right now kyle
uh you're paying your bills on time uh
with your electricity pill
your electricity bill that you're paying
every single month you're paying your
bills on time with your water bill
there's so much history that you have
that if you okay take that history right
and you go to them say hey can you print
off a history of my rent payments print
off history of my electricity payments
my utility payments all this type of
stuff and you bring that to a bank that
does
manual underwriting they will look at
that history
and grant you an approval for a home
loan not just because you have good
payment history
because you also have forty thousand
dollars sitting in the bank at 40
at 24 years old you're also making 70
000 a year and you're not bondage into
any debt
man you they will eat you alive they
will say yes
son let's go we will give you the house
that you want
because you are the best candidate for
this
particular loan so when i hear people
say oh my gosh i'm scared of
credit score i'm saying shut up because
the credit score doesn't mean anything a
700 credit score just simply means
you love paying your debt so cal that's
what i'm gonna tell you man
this is what i'm gonna tell i'm gonna
calm down cause i don't wanna i don't
wanna frustrate you
i know you're hearing like man anthony i
just asked a simple question are you
going off for me i ain't going off on
you
i'm going off in america but here's the
thing
cut up the credit card bro focus on
building
your net worth focus on putting cash
in the account focus on
building your dreams rock out with ken
coleman let's figure out how
how do we get you six figures let's
figure out how do we get six
figures in your savings six figures in
your investments let's figure out how
when you get this home
you pay it off and you own every single
thing don't worry about a credit score
right now you need to worry about
manual underwriting put more money into
your savings account
i see you're in toledo ohio so you can
get to a pretty good home right around
175 to about 300 000
get 20 of that set inside a savings
account
cut up your credit cards get your income
up i mean you're doing great
thousand dollars a year fantastic yeah
so you're a great candidate but don't
fall into the trap that america is
trying to do bro
i'm telling you right now you're in a
great place listen to me
listen to ken listen to dave and you'll
be all right yeah kyle i'm just going to
add add something to what ayo said he's
absolutely right you need to cut the
credit card up
you're such a disciplined kid you
probably think that's okay but it's not
it's just a temptation that you don't
need
cut it up by the way when you pay that
off that'll actually
that'll give you a little bit of bump in
your credit score probably so so
there's your little thing but that's not
why we're telling you to do it yeah but
here's the deal
don't also fall into the trap that i'm
24
i'm gainfully employed making good money
so i'm throwing money away every month
on rent
that is a lie that is a total myth i
just want to walk you through something
really quick so we can get you to a
place where you realize
oh i've been buying into a myth how much
of a house do you think you want to buy
i know you've already looked into it so
what price range are you thinking yeah
um so yeah so i was i was considering a
300 000
house okay because it's really hard to
get a house with a yard
and i want a yard for my dog yeah i get
that but again you're 24 man
slow your roll your dog's fine you can
go out and walk the dog
that's how you meet the ladies anyway
right ao absolutely been a long time for
me i don't know how anybody meets women
anymore but the point is
it works it's like you don't need a yard
for your dog okay but let's just say 300
000
is a reasonable amount of house for you
all right then
then we recommend a minimum of a twenty
percent down payment and do the math
yeah ten to twenty ten to twenty okay we
like twenty ten will work yeah
the point is is that you've got time to
save up more money absolutely and what
ao said is absolutely right because that
puts you in a position having even a
bigger down payment
which means you keep those expenses low
and you're
you're already further down the path to
pay that house off because you are a
financially responsible young man i can
hear it
so don't let that money burn a hole in
your pocket you're not
wasting money by renting do you hear
what we're saying
yeah absolutely all right because that's
a myth so
just another quick question real quick
so what i'm listening
i've heard that uh that like dave says
like hey you're a young guy you're
probably going to move soon with your
jobs and such
yeah like so you're saying i should buy
a house not rent
and and what i heard previously was like
are you going to say
are you moving yeah are you moving
anytime soon i'm not planning on
within five years okay right then it'd
be fine so everything we just said still
the same
but don't get in this big hurry yeah you
know and here's the other thing
if i'm 24 i'm single and i could and i
could buy a 200 000 house
that's more than enough space for me i'm
not going to buy a 300 000
house ao it's just for a yard for my dog
for him i'm buying actually a townhouse
with a good backyard
i mean that's what i'm doing and this
way i can pay it off
yeah save up money so when i get married
boom i could buy a bigger house and rent
that that's where i'm going you know
what i'm saying thank you man thank you
get that double income so now you guys
can be married
debt free no house payment that's the
idea if you got to buy something
just buy what you need that's got some
nice investment
opportunity attached to it don't get to
hurry your dog doesn't care how big the
yard is
trust me hey don't move four of your
calls coming up
right around the corner this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague anthony
o'neil and we're taking your questions
about money
your work and your career how you move
up
maybe you need to move out maybe to
switch
all because you've got a goal you've got
a very clear mountain you want to climb
ayo and i are here to team up to help
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five find out your for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal
rules and restrictions apply
well i'm sorry i was reading this
question and i like the way
i like this one yeah this is all this is
right down your alley
today's question king comes from jake in
missouri
hey anthony because i'm the only one
single when
you are doing your budget what category
would you put dating expenses and paying
for dating apps
i actually want to know the answer to
this james i'm really looking forward to
this
or would you make that his own separate
category
also ao because i'm the only one single
how much money would you put in it
should it be a percent of your income or
just an
overall dollar amount now before you
answer this i've never looked forward
to an answer as much as i'm looking
forward to this answer to the blinds.com
question of the day take
and by the way single people all over
the world in america they're listening
and they're going talk to me
hey man listen man but you know the
reason why i'm laughing is because in
the single world when you mention you're
on a budget that's
actually a turn off it is actually a
turn off to single ladies like oh you're
a jeep no i ain't gee
i just have a clear budget for what
we're doing
when you are dating you should have a
line item on your
um your budget uh that says dating
um and you know there's different kind
of things out there dating can mean
multiple ladies or multiple guys
uh but dating just simply hey for this
month i'm going to spend x amount of
dollars on on
going out on a date and so for me as a
single person who
is dating um i do have a line item it's
not really a percentage
um it's not really a certain amount once
i cover my four walls
okay once i cover my utilities my
housing my transportation and my food
and my mandatory bills um and then if i
had that as long as i am
eliminating my uh debt then i'll set
aside whatever you feel
comfortable um setting aside so if
that's 50
for the month great if that's 150 for
the month great
um i wouldn't definitely do a large
amount and in a large percentage
i would just definitely sit back and say
you know what hey you know i'm gonna go
out on a couple of dates this this
uh this month um with my
young lady who i am dating or my young
man who i'm dating and um
we're gonna go to the movies and go out
to you know get a nice little meal cool
great put that on a
separate line item and i and for me it's
up underneath my
leisure category so like just spinning
stuff now these dating apps i mean
come over to my show i'll talk to you
about the dating apps i don't really
feel comfortable talking about
dating apps on the ramsay show oh very
well there oh look at that i was very
political you might as well be running
for congress
nobody because i can go a little bit
deeper on the table with anthony o'neil
right
but i mean anything around dating yes
you do want to have a line item
make sure you cover your priorities and
make sure that it is not
a lot but make sure it is comfortable to
where you can't enjoy yourself you know
what occurs to me
uh is uh you know james kelly we're
married right so dates with my wife it's
it's a little different than when you're
single
so ao i'm wondering uh if this in when
you're single in the single game are you
spending more
on those initial dates uh or do you
spend less and eventually ratchet it up
versus like date night for us
take stacey out to dinner it's just nice
to get away from the kids i mean we're
at that stage where it's like just a
nice dinner
uh three hours of conversation with no
kids is
fabulous when you've been you know
married as long as i have and have kids
you know
you know i was slammed last year because
i did a video and i said my first date
on anyone who i go out with i will not
spend no more than fifty dollars
this is what i was wondering i like this
you're kind of going
we're prospecting right now i'm not
gonna invest a lot here yeah i'm not i
mean i
like this i i don't want to sit here and
spend 150
on a woman that i may not even see or
want to be you know
oh yeah as in what you're cheap oh yeah
because ladies like 50 dollars i mean
i can't even get a steak for 50 well
first off you're not gonna get a steak
with me on our first date
you know i mean i've been able to this
is fantastic
my savings account looks looks good now
because i've been a good
steward of my money what does the lady
get on a first date with you
oh man what she's gonna get she's gonna
get my heart she'll she's gonna get
intentionality
she's gonna get creativity so we're
gonna go to the park
chicken and a salad the kids menu no
dessert
i'm just saying like she's gonna see
okay he put thought behind this date
we're gonna go to a museum
we're gonna go walk in the park i'm
gonna you know maybe cook something from
the house and bring it on a little
picnic and then we sit down and
you know we watch the stars she's gonna
see creativity
and then once again tupperware
apparently absolutely you know i have no
shame in my game
all right this is good stuff here uh i
think it's good you're taking a stand
young man out there you don't have to
blow the budget on the first date is the
takeaway that's my takeaway
and uh this is a good point here if you
want to go deeper
with ao on stuff like this and he does
and it's fabulously entertaining
the table with anthony o'neil now is
available as a podcast it's already
wildly popular on youtube just search
the table
with anthony o'neil and then again it's
wherever you listen to podcasts
and man he's going into this and all
kinds of stuff and let me tell you about
my man
he brings it oh yeah there's no filter
oh yeah so there you go go check that
out all right
speaking of the single life and recently
engaged uh we're gonna go to loma linda
california
where jan joins us jan how can we help
hi how you doing hi ken hi anthony hey
man how are you good to talk with you
what's up yeah good talk with you too uh
first i just want to say thank you
you've been a big blessing in my life i
just got introduced to both of you and
uh dave ransomed the whole team
about a month ago and i've been
listening to you all
on youtube so it's been great fantastic
second
yeah second uh i graduated from loma
linda actually university
with a 180 000 loan as a physical
therapist
immediately after that i got a dui ended
up
not being able to practice physical
therapy and i ended up getting a job at
yosemite national park as a ranger and i
worked there for about five years
ended up coming back to the profession
under probation
with the board uh in last year may so
2020
and so since then i've been working like
maniac
uh and paying off my dad with the
compound interest that came up to 247
and i paid down so far
about 80 to 83 000 good for you
working multiple jobs uh recently got
engaged about two weeks ago
and congrats yeah congratulations
thank you yeah i guess i'm having i'm
really good i'm
i'm frugal and i'm good at saving
but i'm not good at budgeting i mean i i
do have a budget a mental budget but i'm
not good at writing it
and uh with me and my fiance now are
sitting down and listening to you guys
uh so you know she's she's on board but
we don't have
a concrete foundation and i just wanted
to get some advice
doll ao can help you there how does he
budget better
yeah man i think for you you have a
bigger i think you have a bigger
question than just budgeting
i think with you and your wife just now
getting married um
jan and i want to say congrats um i
think love
true love uh god center love trump's
debt so i want to root you on in that
one and
get married now i think what you and
your wife have to do is sit down and
really
identify what's your vision where are
you going in life once you can get that
clear vision and that clear why of
why you all are going this route man i'm
telling you right now it's going to help
then number two you got to take debt off
of the table both of you all need to
stop
borrowing money and then number three
you all need to
together uh join our uh
financial peace university via ramsey
plus
so what i want to do because you just
got engaged a few weeks ago i want you
to stay on the line
kelly is going to get your information
we're going to give you a free year of
ramsay plus ken and i
uh because we want to sow a seed into
your marriage so your main
responsibility right now
is sit down get the vision and get the
why for you and your new wife
number two take dead off for the table
and immediately get inside of ramsay
plus so you can create a solid
foundation
and learn how to budget learn how to pay
off a debt learn how to start building
well
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague anthony
o'neil and we're taking your questions
as we do here on the ramsey show to help
you get where you want to go
how many of you are in a job that you
just you don't know if you can bear
doing it much longer
it's toxic you've got a leadership issue
above you you just feel like you're
topped out you can't go any further
some of you don't even know what it is
you really would like to do you want to
make more money you want to do something
that you love but you're not quite sure
i can take those questions for you
that's what we do on the ken coleman
show which is a part of the ramsey
network
you got your money questions you got
some of those relationship questions
you're single
you're trying to figure out some stuff
there ao handles all of those questions
uh on the table with anthony o'neil part
of the ramsey
network as well so we're going to talk
about life
in the form of money your work career
what you're called to do where you want
to go relationships
goals i'm sitting next to a guy who
and he's all about excellence and
maximizing potential he and i are
uh both passionate about that message so
hey we wanna help you
phone lines are open triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five danielle is joining us
now in louisville kentucky danielle how
can we help
[Music]
hey how are you guys doing oh we're
having a blast what's going on with you
awesome hey i actually spoke to you guys
a few months back but um
me and my husband are kind of at odds um
we're
finishing up baby step 3a and getting
ready to go into baby step 3b
um however i had a question
right now we owe currently 93 000 about
our current house and we're wanting to
save at least 10 to 20
down for another house with a little bit
bigger yard that's a little bit nicer
for our kids
the question i have is by the time
in my head by the time we save up that
much money we could have already had our
house paid off
and we'd end up using that money to pay
off our house would it be better to
continue doing what we're doing like
paying the mortgage and doing all that
stuff and saving for a house
would it be better to just work on
paying our house off first and then
saving up for
another house how much is your house
worth right now if you were to put it on
the market
130 000 that said hundred and thirty and
you overnight you owe 93 on it
yes okay and i'm guessing that he's at
odds with that that's how you started
the program
excuse me the call as you as you enter
the program so
so why is he at odds with that the idea
of hey we could pay it off
and then we'd have if we sold it for 130
we'd have all 130
to use uh versus the 20 you're gonna try
to put down what what's his problem with
that
i think our his problem is like he's
like do we
if if we pay it off then
we're basically using our money that we
were supposed to be paying for
um a new house and paying our house off
and then we're gonna have to start from
scratch and redo everything like it's
gonna
take us at least five to six years to
pay to get the seventy thousand dollars
or whatever twenty percent down
but by the time we do that that's
basically all the money we can do for
paying the house
and we'll be in this house a lot longer
how much of a house are you trying to uh
purchase
uh four bedroom two bath how much is
that
it's gonna be about two hundred thousand
okay two hundred thousand hit where we
wanna be
like with a nicer yard and right now we
live in the middle of town and on a big
street and
it's not safe for my dog it's not safe
for my kids yeah yeah
well what's interesting is what's
interesting is you just identified some
things that you don't like
and yet you're the one kind of going i
think we just pay off the house
yeah that's where we're like i don't
know what's going on i'm getting
confused he's getting confused and it's
like okay what should we do yeah uh
what's y'all's household income right
now
uh he makes about um about
70 to 80 000. okay and are you uh stay
at home one year
i am a stay-at-home mom i i had worked
during the covet era and then i had to
stop
okay cool so here's the thing that i
really want you to understand
one of the key things we teach is um 10
to 20
down the reason why we teach 20 is so
that you can avoid pmi
okay private mortgage insurance but we
don't have a problem with you putting 10
percent
so 10 of 200 000 is right at 40 000.
um and with you all making 80 000
a year if you sell your house and i
heard you say
it as in like the app or like zillow
told you
that it was worth 130 000 i would pull
in one of one of our
indoor social providers a realtor that
can come out
uh really appraise your house in this
market and let you know okay this is
exactly what you can get for your house
if zillow was saying 130 i'm gonna guess
you're right around 145
in this market you only need 40 000 to
get the 10
okay so honestly if y'all have any more
money in 3b
you may be around 15 and what you all
can do two options you can go ahead and
move into the house with 10 to 15
to put down and work towards getting
that extra five percent into your x
years and refi and get out of the pmi
um or you can move into an apartment
for a year stack up some more money and
then put in the 20
get the 20 down but the bare minimum
here at ramsey solutions we teach
10 bare minimum 20 um it's a second idea
then the first idea
is of course is to pay cash but the
majority of us listening including
myself are not going to pay
cash uh for the house so the second one
is 20
bare minimum 10. so i would definitely
say number one reach out to a realtor
go to daveramsey.com uh look at one of
our indoor social provider realtors ask
them to come out give you the proper
appraisal of what you can do with the
house
if they come back to where you can sell
it for 145 150
after fees and everything you have you
know at least forty thousand dollars put
into the home
then i would say go ahead and look into
it i mean because you guys are already
debt free
just make sure you do not touch your
baby step three which is you have three
to six months of your expenses for
emergencies
but if you can use the equity to get
into a bigger house for you and your
family
that's okay yeah and you know and again
i think it's good for you
for you two to sit down just emotionally
and let's just talk about this
we understand the financial piece let's
talk about the emotional piece yeah
yeah let's just look at this and go what
do we want this house for what are all
these reasons and you've already listed
them out better place for the kids
better bedroom situation and all that
and if you look at that and you go again
the 10
we can get the 10 down payment a lot
faster than we can pay the 93 off
then you need to be okay with that yeah
because it's not there's no wrong
decision here because you guys are
living this out you're walking the baby
steps
so this is less about right and wrong
this is about what do we want to do and
get on the same page i don't think you
guys are that far apart does it sound
like to me
but i think i think i would list list
out those you know pros and cons of the
emotional why we want this
and then financially we can get there
triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number to
jump in triple eight
eight two five five two two five uh hey
i want you to weigh in on a question i
got on instagram
bethany wrote in i want to break out on
my own and do my own thing before i turn
30
but i'm not sure yet what i want to do
i'm not sure how to figure it out can
you give me a little advice
i just don't know what i just know that
i don't want to work for someone else
for the rest of my life so i'm going to
talk about that
little sitting on the back end because i
think that's what's driving a lot of
frustration for this young lady
okay the first thing is she's had a bad
experience working for somebody else yes
she also has probably always had a
little bit of an entrepreneurial spirit
all right so then let's go back up to
the first sentence i want to break out
on my own
and do my own thing before i turn 30.
that's speaking to this
she's got this she's got a vision and uh
and so of course i
you know i teach look at your talent
what you do best those are the premium
tools
you don't want to show up and do some
construction work with bad tools ayo
right so we look at what you're most
talented at then we look at the kind of
work that you've always thought about
the kind of work you love to do
that's what we call passion and then
what are the results that you want to
create them
in the world and a young lady like this
she's already dreamed a little bit ayo
she's thought about what i want to do
yeah and you you've seen young kids with
the stars in their eyes
yeah and they got to be careful not to
try to do it too soon
i'm so glad you said that ken you're the
career expert in this space man and i
think oftentimes
you know you see these young kids
they're looking at the big names out
there like oh man i need to have my own
business oh man i need to be out on my
own oh man i need to work for myself
well yeah great i think that's a great
goal but anyone
i would never want to work for someone
or work with someone who never had to
work for
someone because if you don't know how to
lead if you don't if you don't know how
to be led if you don't know how to
submit someone else's vision and learn
up underneath someone else then you will
you will not know how to lead
you will not know how uh to treat your
people your team members your staff
members
so for me i say young people uh get it
learn as much as you possibly can
then follow ken's advice and go start
your own business one day good stuff
he is anthony o'neil i'm ken coleman and
i want to thank
our producer james childs our associate
producer kelly daniel
but most of all you america thank you
for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
your money your relationships
winning being who you were created to be
i'm ken coleman host of the ken coleman
show on the ramsey network
and i'm joined by my colleague anthony
o'neil host of the table with anthony
o'neil on the ramsey network and we are
your hosts this hour triple eight eight
two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five a o always good to be
with you
tell these people uh why
doing work you love allows them to make
more money in your opinion i talk about
this all the time
i want to know what you think about it
well i'm not as polished and and
expertise in this area as you are man
you're an expert in it you've done
it hey man you know i think for me when
you are doing the work that you're
passionate about
um you put more energy behind it you put
more effort into it and when you put
more energy and effort into it if you're
in a career space at a corporate america
your bosses will see you and elevate you
and give you more opportunities uh
so i think for me when you just when you
when you love what you do
uh it's evidence in your work the money
follows yes and the right amount of
money
it doesn't always have to be more money
than anybody else and that's why
the the baby steps coincide
with the seven stages of meaningful work
so we're going to take some work
questions if you're not happy ayo and i
can weigh in on this he's been in
leadership
uh at a large large mega church he
understands the dynamics we'll also talk
about your money
uh we'll talk relationships my man's
single over here so when you talk about
being single and money
he can bring it so we'll take your
questions about life money whatever
angle you want to come at it triple
eight eight 825-5225
let's go to columbus ohio where adriana
is on the line adriana how can we help
hi um i was calling because
i have purchased a new vehicle um
about two years ago now for a total of i
believe 13
or 14 000 one of those um i still
owe 11 000 on the vehicle but
my car note is extremely
high it's like 360 a month
so i have tried refinancing
through a couple of companies and i just
get generic
denials even though my credit has
improved over 200 points
since i originally got the
loan for the car so i have gotten some
suggestions that maybe
i should consider selling and getting a
cheaper vehicle
paying off the rest or whatever um but
right now i feel kind of like my hands
are tied
um i've still got two years to go on the
loan
and i would like to be rid of it asap
how much money are you making adriana
what's your uh
yearly income um 36
36 000. okay cool what do you do for a
living
um construction um and call center
manager
okay okay call center man okay cool
games and any other debt outside of this
uh
car like student loans credit cards
nope okay so the only debt that you have
is this
11 000 on a car which is about 360
dollars a month
yeah what's the blue book value on it
have you looked it up
um i'm believing nine maybe
and you owe 11. yeah okay do you have
any money in the savings right now
um maybe like nothing extreme like 2k
okay 2k how old are you adriana i'm
24. 24. you're a young lady okay cool
beans i like this i like you calling
asking the question
um let me ask you this question too why
do you want a refund you want a lower
payment
yes basically to free up some um
extra money because i am also a single
mother
okay and um yeah i would like to have
more money
in the month how many kids do you have
just one
cool great um um here's the thing
when it comes to refinancing adriana
i don't teach refinancing we don't teach
refinancing to get a lower payment
so you can stay in debt longer we teach
refi
so you can get a lower interest rate so
you're not paying
as much penalties but your payment still
is going to be as high as it possibly
can so you can get out of debt
quicker so the the the solution to your
problem is not refinancing
it's it's getting out of the car um
if you're saying that you're living
uncomfortably right now
um that you know just paying 360 dollars
a month
right now which 36 thousand dollars a
year
means you're bringing home about maybe
28 to 29
000 dollars a year i can understand that
and so right now if you have two
thousand dollars in your savings
um right now you really need to talk to
ken because we gotta get your income up
for one
uh we gotta get that shovel bigger uh
because even if you sow the car
today how do we pay cash
how much money and how much time would
it take for you to save up cash
to go buy a cash vehicle to free up to
360
a month and so my suggestion to you is
not trying to refi to get down to 150
payment
because you're just going to be in debt
a lot longer and you're going to pay
so much more for this car than what it's
actually worth yeah
so your number one thing is get out of
the car
get your shovel bigger and go buy a cash
car yeah and i think we can get you out
of this
pretty quick yeah uh ao is exactly right
so
let's just walk through some
possibilities okay let's try to create a
plan based on your reality
could you work a second job without you
know
creating too much more expense on child
care could you do that if it is
additional 15 hours a week or something
like that what's realistic for you
um i could potentially i wouldn't
necessarily see a second job but
i'm sure i can put some some pressure to
my commissions
okay so that's my point so how much and
you don't have to answer this
on the air but i think the question
you've got to answer before monday give
you a couple days you know you're kind
of walking through this and kind of go
before the next week starts
how much more money do i feel
comfortable that i can create
in my budget okay and so what happens is
let's say
let's just run some round numbers all
right let's say that you could make an
additional
500 a month all right and i'm talking
net
so after taxes let's say you could put
an additional 500 a month
towards that car you've got 2 000 in
savings right now
so if you walk the baby steps out okay
baby step one is a thousand dollars
you've got two thousand so you could put
a thousand dollars on the car
today so that takes it now to i o ten
thousand
let's say that you could put 500 a month
and so let's say for four months
okay you're just looking at the numbers
four or five months uh
and you're knocking that down several
thousand dollars more all right so you
go from 10
000 to uh in a couple of four months and
i could do
it down to 8 000 and then if i oh i said
oh i'm making some ground here
and if i keep i keep hustle a little bit
longer i get this down to 4 000.
let's say it's worth nine you said it
was worth nine you sell it
okay you got thousand dollars cash to go
buy
a decent car that will take care of you
and your child and guess what just
happened
the 360 dollar payment that you wanted
to refinance
goes to zero i think that's what we want
to see you do
hustle so you can get some help with the
child care that doesn't cost you any
money because you're casting a vision ao
you're saying hey i'm gonna bust it for
six seven eight months trying to make as
much money as i can
to where i can sell that car and still
buy something
now you're free i'm truly debt free i
love it watch you pile the money up
you've got this
i love single mothers ao they're the
strongest people on the planet
you can do this yes this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues thrilled to
have you with us i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague
anthony o'neal and we are taking your
questions triple eight eight two five
five two two five you wanna talk money
you wanna talk
your work and moving up in your career
making a switch
we are here for you triple eight eight
two five
five two two five is the number
chelsea is up next in fayetteville
arkansas chelsea how can we help
hey so my 16 year old is starting her
first job this week
and the two of us have been trying to go
over her
budget and um so we
are wondering if you could give us some
uh tips
on like what percentages to go where her
and i are kind of butting heads about it
because i'm the nerd and i'm like
match your 401k do your retirement and
she's like
i'm 16. what are you talking about
well i kind of see both sides of this
ayo yeah i really do
i really do what would you do man you
you are a father
well yeah i'll tell you so in this
situation
uh she's 16. and and so um
i want uh her to get the basics
but she doesn't have many expenses i i
don't know what you're requiring for her
to pay what
so let me walk you through because i
know this i'm gonna make my kid pay for
his gas
right right i'll cover insurance right
you know but he's going to pay for gas
what are you making her pay what
expenses does she have
that are hers well so up until this
point
we have not made her pay insurance or
car or gas because she's had a 10
a week allowance until this point um and
now she's
making 13 an hour working about 15 hours
a week
so how many hours a week about 15.
okay gotcha and so you want her putting
money into a 401k account
well i i mean my goal if i had my way
would be
you know 10 to giving uh the match
whatever the company match is 6 for a
401k and then the rest of it in
the rest of um her savings and would
just go into a savings account where she
wants to buy a car
sure i get it and what is she pushing
back
she is pushing back on the total
percentage
of savings what does she want what does
she want to save
she wants to save maybe 20 percent
and you want her to save how much
shavings
my what i would love with this b2c40 and
that's what we do with her allowance
right now ten percent goes to tithing
40 goes to savings i get it and she's on
board with the she's on board with the
tithing correct
yes she is okay great so ayo uh you you
could speak to the budgie in the forums
but as a father
um i'm not going to let this be a big
battle i'm not going to die on the hill
versus
of 20 she's willing to save 20 you want
her to save 40.
i'm gonna go i think you should save
more and here's why
but this is your money it's your job if
you think 20 is the right number
okay and chill out mom you're
practically driving a stake in the
ground for her
on 20 but i just don't think i'd fight
that
hey yo i really wouldn't either um and i
definitely want to say
uh chelsea your heart is such a this is
so amazing that you
you want to teach your daughter how to
win financially
there's three things that i teach when
it comes to young people how to give
how to save and how to spend give safe
spend give
give your 10 to your local church or
give to you know
to the needy teach our young people how
to have a generous
heart so you're already doing that with
their local church they're not that it's
safe
i agree uh with the saving part as far
as in 401ks and i see that but
what i didn't hear and correct me and
and
make sure you tell me this here i just i
didn't hear anything about saving for
college
saving for her first car saving for prom
saving for
you know things that she's going to be
experiencing
um i heard say 401k they're gonna do a
match
save for this save for that that's cool
that's great but let's make sure that
we're also teaching her to save for the
things that she's going to have to
experience
and saving for college is more important
than saving in a 401k
saving to contribute towards her first
car even if you all have the means to
pay for her first car is
more important than contributing to a
roth ira that's correct
and so i would definitely teach that
part
have that conversation let her get into
some part
of ownership of her life and then spend
let her enjoy her money you know because
she's working hard for it
let her go out there and and and you
know get her hair done get her nails
done
and buy something cute so when she go to
school you know her girl's like girl i
like that new hair
you know so i mean so you got to figure
it out you know give safe spent
so those are the three things there's
really not a percentage
um that we teach we just want to teach
the overall method
then as she gets older then of course
we'll dive deeper into it but right now
at 16 those are the three things you
should be teaching her
and i just say one last thing mom and
this is coming from i'm figuring this
out right now with a 15 and 13 and 12.
um learn how to coach a little bit and
the way you coach
is uh you let them go out and try that
sport right yeah
and then you give them some notes and
you say let's go out and play and then
let's teach you how to do the
fundamentals so
you know let her come up with a plan as
she begins to make the money and then
spend the money and save the money then
you kind of coach a little bit after
you've watched it you know you
you don't expect a kid when they try a
new sport or learn a new instrument to
just get it right away
what do what do you do you let them
practice you let them play it
and it is the act of practicing and
playing and performing
by which they really learn how to do it
and i take a i would just take a chill
out approach
um and and let them feel that
responsibility and the sting by the way
of making a bad purchase because right
now is the time
you know if i want my kid making a dumb
purchase it's when
they're 16. yes and they're not homeless
and if they run out of money i go great
you're not going anywhere this
weekend because you can't put gas in
your car but it's not a crisis and i
think
i think it's hard for i'm struggling
with this i i've seen the middle on the
air i'm a control freak as a parent i'm
learning how not to be
but it's because of our fears in come as
a control freak yeah well i know that's
no surprise to you
but you know but it's like hey you know
i got to let them learn ayo
you do and see you've come at it from a
youth pastor like you've been
partnering with parents and going oh we
don't want him to make any mistakes at
all because we don't want him to suffer
any pain and yet
it is that pain uh albeit very small for
a 16 year old financially
that actually teaches the best lesson
and here
and you're absolutely right ken i am not
a parent so i'm not a parent personality
uh but i spent 10 years of my life
being a big brother to thousands and
thousands of young people and one of the
biggest
um things that i that i saw wrong within
homes again not as a parent but as a
youth pastor
uh was parents forced their kids to do
something
and then i think the problem is when you
force them to live this lifestyle
the moment they become free they want to
leave that lifestyle
rachel says it's best more is caught
than taught and i believe more is
caught than forced and so it's like hey
just just give your kids that option
give your kids the opportunity
to say yes and to say no and when they
say no just
okay cool great you're going to fall in
my house
i'm going to let you fall and feel a
little bit of that pain
and while i'm helping you get back up
i'm going to educate you on why you fail
and why you feel the pain and then when
they feel that pain up underneath
loving up underneath wisdom up
underneath care
more than likely they're not going to
want to feel that pain again true story
so i know everybody go to break here but
i remember when i was uh like
three four years old and my parents
always tell me don't touch the stove
don't touch the stove
well one day i went to touch the stove
my dad saw me going to touch the stove
so he let me
walk towards the stove went inside of
the refrigerator took out the butter
followed me to the stove and as soon as
i went up there to touch the stove
my dad already had some butter in his
hand and before i can even really scream
as soon as i touched it he grabbed my
hand rub the
butter on my hand and i'm looking at my
dad that hurt and he said do you see why
i told you
to not touch the stove while i am in
pain while my dad is educating me and
while he's making sure that i am okay
you know to this day as a grown man
i do not want to touch the stove i'm
sure you know because it's like i re i
know what it feels like
but i know what it feels like because my
father allowed me
to feel the pain up underneath his care
wisdom and judgment and i think that's
what parents need to do be
willing to allow your kids to feel a
little bit while you're there to educate
them because if they feel it in the
world
with no education they'll keep doing it
folks that right there
that'll teach and that'll preach
and it works good stuff ao i feel like i
didn't call your dad during the
commercial break
tell them how awesome that is seriously
as a dad i'm going man that's beautiful
that's so so good love it tell you what
else i love
more of your calls and they're coming up
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman
i'm joined by my colleague anthony
o'neal
and our colleague dr john deloney is uh
is is in the control room he has found
his way to the control room and he's uh
he's uh he came to uh to talk to anthony
o'neil about the
topic we were talking about uh in a
previous hour about
uh how much money you should spend on
the first
date and this you said fifty dollars
fifty
dollars and this is this is the reason
why john delaney is not a money
personality because he said i should
spend
a thousand dollars he did not say that
you two will be on air together soon and
james we will let them continue that
ongoing debate in a future ramsey
show all right hey uh when it comes to
making big money or life moves like
buying a home getting married or having
a baby it's likely the last thing
that is on your mind is making sure you
have the right insurance coverage
i get it and those big changes are
overwhelming but
what would be even more overwhelming is
to find yourself in a situation where
you and your family
were in a hole because you weren't
covered properly it's
not having the time or energy that is
keeping you from getting the right
coverage use one of our endorsed local
provider or
elp insurance agents to help elps are
independent agents
who find you the best coverage at the
best price free of charge
an independent agent shops a variety of
insurance
options finds you the best coverage and
explains
all of the technical lingos so that you
know exactly what you're getting for
free
now all you have to do is text insurance
just the word insurance
text that to 33789 to get connected with
an elp
and get the coverage that fits you
that's insurance text that to 33789
all right triple eight eight two five
five two two five
that's the number let's go to kayla who
joins us in louisville kentucky kayla
how can we help
hi guys thank you for taking my call you
bet what's up
um so my husband and i we have been
married for almost a year
and we brought our home um and it was a
we needed to renovate it and so we
loaned
fifty thousand dollars from my husband's
father
um to kind of finance those renovations
hey kayla
kayla i'm sorry i'm sorry to interrupt
if you could try to get that phone and
hold it right on your mouth you're
coming in and out it's making it hard
for us to hear your question could you
start over and try that
yes i'm sorry is this better a little
bit let's see how it goes
okay so my husband and i we bought a
home about a year ago
and we financed our renovations through
his father
and we borrowed about fifty thousand
dollars from him
and i have um and some mutual funds
about fifty four thousand dollars
um should we cash out those mutual funds
to
pay his dad off or should we just
continue to make payments
to his dad and just let that money kind
of sit in the mutual fund
ah man um whoo
man borrowing money from family is is to
me that's worse than borrowing money
from the bank
are you feeling pressure um from him to
get it sooner
is that why you're considering uh using
your mutual fund which by the way the
answer is unequivocally no you're not
going to touch your mutual fund
you're not going to pay it back that way
let's get that out of the way i'm just
curious why you're even thinking about
that
um we are kind of trying to do the debt
snowball
and our mortgage is the last thing that
we like owe money on
and so we weren't really sure like if
his loan to his dad qualified as
part of like our mortgage um so we were
just trying to like
get that paid off so we could say okay
we're done with that
yeah let me answer this question what
what other kind of debt do you have
right now
um we just have our mortgage and that
it's we have about four we owe him about
forty thousand now we've made
we're making about two thousand dollar a
month payments
to him what's your household that's all
we have um we make about a hundred
thousand
s combined yes okay cool great
and then you only owe him about forty
thousand dollars from what you're saying
correct
right cool how much money do you have in
your savings right now
um we have about 10 000 10 or 12 000
okay 10 or 12 okay cool great so um
one thing that ken said earlier which uh
there's there's different kinds of
mutual funds you have mutual funds that
are covered in retirements like via
uh like a roth ira or traditional ira um
that is covered and invested into a
growth stock mutual fund and then you
have mutual funds that are not covered
with retirement
so to be clear are these mutual funds
covered from in retirement
or is it just regular mutual funds
standing on their own
um these are just regular mutual funds
they were actually
it was actually funds that my parents
had like saved for me growing up
okay so they're not retiring they're not
your 401k retirement stuff and roth okay
yeah we have we have separate like
growth irons for that
oh okay all right well correct me
correct correct me on that one then yeah
it's good it's good it's good yeah team
players here that's why i assumed i
assume those are retirement accounts so
let me clear that up
yeah so we would not want you to touch
your retirement because you can take a
tax hit on that
exactly but these are separate from
retirement which you've cleared up
then yes yeah for an example because i
you know i actually
put money into a mutual fund now to say
to build up my dream home and so
whenever i get into that season i will
i will pull from that and that's okay uh
and so for yourself here here's what i'm
going to recommend
i'm going to say um you have two options
here you could take the 12k and put that
towards your dad's stuff right now
or you can go ahead and cash out the
mutual fund and pay
off your debt entirely and keep the ten
thousand dollars
inside of that if i'm you i'm going to
cash out my mutual fund
and go ahead and pay off my debt
entirely and keep the emergency fund
narrow to ten to twelve thousand dollars
a month
right there not a month but the ten to
twelve thousand dollars in my savings
account
so that way you can get out of debt you
all are 100
debt free and all the money you have now
is going towards building your wealth
you're investing it into your 401ks and
into your roth iras
and even into your kids college future
um down the road
so that's what i would do i wouldn't
play with it i would go ahead and just
pay off my dad pay off my father-in-law
and keep on moving
yeah good stuff there uh you cringed
when she when she started the call and
said
i borrowed money from or we did borrow
money from from my father-in-law
uh there's there's a deeper deeper issue
there yeah i mean borrowing money
period is is is a no-go and i've we've
all made that mistake
but with family members man you know
i've had to tell family members in my
own family no i can't
i can't loan you that money uh because
if i can't afford to give it to you
i'm i just can't afford to to give it to
you at all loan it to you at
all um because i've i've seen within
even within my own family
money it just it just doesn't do it
doesn't go well yeah um
so friends family members if i cannot
give it to you
i i just i won't do it and honestly man
growing up
in my young 20s before i started this
philosophy
man i've i've i've i don't have current
relationships right now
right because how i did them right
without giving them back their money on
time so
and that's why you're and that's why
you're going let's go ahead and cash out
the non-retirement mutual funds because
we're gonna we're gonna get that
relationship we're gonna take care of
that not let that
fester right yeah i get it right yeah
yeah it makes a lot of sense it makes a
lot of sense yeah
because it's one of those things where
it's like you never know she didn't
really directly answer you don't know if
that's getting sour
she kind of said hey we want to knock it
out which i get um but
uh bottom line is is that uh um it is it
is something that they can
actually do yeah and save that potential
tension yes and that's that's good yeah
yeah yeah my mic went out there for a
minute
good man yeah yeah you're good yeah and
i think that that's important too
because it's like we we all have these
opportunities to maybe make some
progress if we get money from family
because it feels right yeah right okay
now i can make some progress here
yeah i can jump ahead and all i got to
do is
well i'm not getting it from a bank
right and so it feels right but that's a
trap
yeah yeah absolutely and it feels good
oh it's better i get it from my mom my
dad
my brother my sister oh they'll forgive
me if i don't no man no no listen
nah nah that's not the case and so for
me just
borrowing money period man don't do it
from family and don't
loan family money and in her situation
anyone listening right now if you have
the means of paying
it off for the love of your family for
the sake of your family
paid off yeah bottom line yeah cleans it
all up
yes everybody feels better yes
everybody's excited yeah
got the stuff done and then they're in a
great shape and again you want to point
out that we do believe in the process of
the baby steps
and so they want to knock it off but
they had 10 grand in the bank right and
technically folks we want you to just do
a thousand dollars in that emergency
fund
put the rest of that towards the debt
but they're in a situation where they
can take a big chunk out of this
and knock it out completely so that's a
good thing all right good stuff
good advice anthony o'neil all right
don't move
more ramsey show coming right up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague anthony o'neal
and we are taking your questions we'll
take your questions about
your life that means your money that
means your profession
the kind of income you want the impact
you desire to make
we're going to take it on for you triple
eight eight two five
five two two five open phone lines it is
a free call let's go to jacksonville
florida
where kim joins us kim how can we help
hi thank you for taking my call sure um
i've read both of your books
i learned a lot and um yes and i just
most recently read
your book and the proximity principle
okay
and um there's a lot of good information
but my thing is
like i work because i'm a single mom i
have three kids
and i don't love my job like i don't
feel like there's really any purpose
yeah um like
you know like i'm not contributing
anything really you know
yeah for the good you know it's
basically survival
and i feel like i've been in survival
mode for
so long yeah like i don't even know what
i
would like to do like when i read all of
your great tips you know about okay find
what you want do this do that
i'm like i don't even know where my
passion even lies because
like i said it's survival mode yeah but
um
i mean i want to get there like i want
we're gonna get you fulfilling and of
course
but of course my kids you know you're
number one um
and you know they're turning out great
so um you're doing such a good job
mom hey mom listen you're doing such
a good job and i can hear the emotion in
your voice
and i wanna i to address something real
quick
just because you don't see any
worth in your work doesn't mean that you
aren't making a difference
all right right but i understand that's
why i do the show that i do
for ramsey solutions right because once
you get to a point where you don't
have any juice any passion for the job
there's no connection to the work
it becomes a very slippery slope to
where you feel like well my work doesn't
matter to me and then also you start to
feel like i don't matter and that's
where you are right now but let me tell
you
who you matter to beyond me and anthony
o'neil right now
those three kids think you're the sun
the moon and the stars don't you ever
forget that you hear me
all right all right so real quick i want
to get into this but
when you say survival mode are you
talking financial survival you're just
barely making ends meet
yeah i mean it's been a struggle um
and i did i was i read dave ramsey's
book for the first time i don't know why
i've heard of him for years but i
just i actually got it from my kids in
the fall
and um but i ended up reading it and so
it's given me a lot of
hope even though i'm like when i read it
i'm like we're the single moms in this
book like it's a different situation
but it has given me a plan and i do feel
hopeful but yes
it's been a huge financial struggle so
what do you do now
how much do i make what do you do now
and how much do you make um
last year it was 37 and um
it's an accounting for um like a
district
distribution company so it's not my
passion it's not my degree
but um it's a great work environment and
you know
positive people good all right
yeah and so do you have a lot of debt
no i'm actually um i paid off my last
credit card a couple months ago
kim now listen now listen how old are
the kids we're going to get to this i
want to i want to figure out what you
want to do because i think you know
you're afraid to say it
but we'll get that in a second all right
but how old are the kids
okay the oldest just turned 18 and
anthony she'll be going to college debt
free she got a full paid scholarship
how about that debt-free degree right
there yeah all right so they're not
little and and so what are the other
ages
the other two i'm 15 we're almost 16 and
13.
okay good that's good news that's going
to help me with some advice here in a
second
all right okay so what was your degree
in
a journalism interesting okay so
when kim when somebody tells me on the
ken coleman show or here on the ramsey
show
that they have no idea what work they're
passionate about i know that that's
ultimately not true but they're having a
hard time saying it
getting it out of their head right so i
want to test you on something okay
but i want you to promise me that right
now you're going to turn your brain off
you're not going to think about how you
get there in the form of getting
qualified how much that would cost how
long it would take i want you to suspend
all of that disbelief
and let's assume you're in some fantasy
movie that you went to and you're just
enjoying the movie even though you know
it's not realistic
does that sound good right all right
here we go i want you to answer with
your heart
if you knew you could not fail you did
not have to get qualified
you didn't have to worry about the money
the money was what you needed and then
some
and you didn't have to get qualified i'd
just start you on a monday morning
soon and you knew you couldn't fail but
you also didn't have to commit to it for
the rest of your work life either
what would you try okay i've heard you
ask this question i've tried to answer
it it's not
one specific job i guess what might
that's fine
just talk don't okay you're already
making excuses what is it
okay travel helping others
and culture like those are my passions i
don't know how to make money
hold on hold on that's my job hold on
all right so when you say helping
others in culture describe those people
you want to help
and the problem or the challenge that
they have because i think you know that
so describe the people and the problem
okay mostly um women and children um
like refugees um you know mission type
work which i
i used to do in college um all right now
stop you know
how would you help someone how would you
help them now i know the people
how would you help them what's the
solution you'd want to help them with
what is it well that's the thing like
offer my first thing that comes to mind
is like offer comfort like
be someone to listen to them because i
think okay i don't have
medical skills or construction skills
like the typical things you think of
when you go to do this
hold on you know like kim let me ask you
a question
are you really good at connecting with
people
i think so yes do you love listening to
people
i do yeah you love giving people advice
and encouragement
um yes i do interesting how did i know
that yeah
we've never talked before so kim yeah
here's the deal
you've been overthinking this the fact
of the matter
is a person who goes into journalism has
got verbal skills
you just do you're gifted at
communication you
you're gifted at connecting with others
you're a single mom you've been through
so much and there's a reason why
refugees and women there's a reason from
your past am i right or wrong
um you know i think it's more of i mean
yeah my not so distant past you know
just
you know when going through a divorce
and it's humiliating
it was very public you know you lose
your reputation your privacy all those
things like it changes who you
are and i feel like that's what has
changed me and made me more
empathetic more understanding less
judgmental that's it
so there it is if your why doesn't make
you cry it's not your why and kim
you're why is all over you you're just
having a hard time articulating and i
think the real issue is you're dealing
with doubt you're going i don't know if
there's anything i can do to help those
women that's
garbage and you know it you can help
those women
if it's a mission field then get after
it so here's the deal
your homework assignment is to look for
all the ways just real jobs whether it
be on the mission field
or working in a government local or
state agency that's helping women that
are battered
uh or are single moms and they and
they're they're behind the eight ball
and they're on welfare and government
benefits or whatever and they feel like
they can't ever get out of this hole
uh right uh ministries that are helping
those women your job is to just do the
research and say
who's helping those women that i want to
help and then go what am i qualified to
do and if there's something that you
want to do you're not qualified for
you figure out how to do that and you
ask these questions what do i need to
learn
what's basic certification do i need i
got news for you you probably won't need
much
you've already got a four year degree
and how much is that going to
how long is it going to take for me to
get that qualification they want
and how much is going to cost me and
then based on that
how long will it take those four simple
questions will come up with a plan
you have raised three kids largely on
your own
there's no stopping you kim nobody can
stop you and your heart is full right
now because you know who you want to
help now all you got to do is find out
how you can help them
and i'm telling you right now you can
make the money that you want to make
37 and more go figure out how to help
those women now and go do it
that is what you're supposed to do
kim i'm so proud of you don't you dare
quit
your heart's on fire let it stay on fire
hey i want to thank
my colleague anthony o'neil i want to
thank our producer james childs
our associate producer kelly daniel and
you america
this has been the ramsay show
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life your money
your work relationships and
more i'm ken coleman and i'm joined by
my colleague anthony o'neil we are
ramsay personalities
we each host a show on the ramsey
network
anthony's show is wildly popular on
youtube and
in podcast form it is the table with
anthony o'neal
and uh mine is named the ken coleman
show we really spent a lot of time on
that one
a lot of creative a lot of creative
force going into naming at the ken
coleman show yeah
but you can find both on the ramsey
network uh
both on youtube both in podcast form and
we are teaming up together to help you
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five so you got a question
uh you want to move up make some more
money
we can talk about that and we can also
get you out of a tough work situation
you got some leadership issues you want
to be a leader
uh you got some relationship questions
single trying to figure out how to spend
that money how to do it how to do it
right
that's the kind of stuff that we are
wide open for all right let's get to the
phones
little rock arkansas is where we go
first taylor is there
taylor how can we help hello hi
i am so excited to talk to you both
um and so this is my question first of
all i
am in baby step two um i am a
single mom i'm currently working um
two jobs and um i am planning to
move this summer to actually take a job
to the dallas fort worth area where
i will get a pay increase
and i will also be able to work my side
job as well
um but um my question is this
during the first couple months
um it will not be
paid i will not be paid and so of course
i'm saving up for that and everything
um but i kind of have a relationship
question too because i am currently
single
but uh but i've been dating um
someone for a while and so we had been
talking about
marriage by the end of this year um
and he had actually told me that he was
planning on uh
proposing soon and so uh i will be
moving closer to him
he lives in that speed uh he actually
lives in that area
as well and so my question is um
is it unfair or is it unrealistic
um that i would expect him to help with
my move
how close are you how long you been
dating how i mean how deep and close is
this relationship
now we've not been dating for a really
long time it's been under a year
that we've been dating but of course uh
we both
um we both are divorced and so we bust
in kind of the bush for a while
and so we can't both know really what
we were looking for how much money how
much money do you need to move to dallas
what are your moving expenses
um i calculate my moving to
moving expenses um probably
probably would be probably about five
thousand dollars and that's including my
rent
and everything for that first couple
months
yeah ayo and i looked at each other i
would not expect him to pay that no
are you expecting him to pay that or are
you just asking if if
you think he should expect what
uh no i'm not expecting him to pay that
one two jobs why'd you ask then
well i wasn't expecting him to pay all
of that
but however he was he was training me
but you're expecting another man that
you've only been dating for less than a
year to expect
to pay some of it uh
well he well he was telling me where to
move
he's trying to tell me where to move
because he wanted us to get engaged
he said he said marriage by the end of
the year is what he had told me
i mean well brothers we could talk a
good game you know that taylor
we could talk a good game and so listen
man let me just tell you this much
and i'm gonna say this and i'm gonna i'm
gonna let ken come in because he's
married
i can't give marriage advice i don't
want to give marriage advice but
um right as a single person
i would advise you to do what is best
for you
not based upon what he is saying if he
hasn't put a ring on your finger before
you moved
he has no say so in what you do how you
do it and where you go
now if you ask him for advice you have
every right to listen to his advice
but move with the intent of
you're going to be there on your own
whether you get married or not
in the next year or two and so for me i
would challenge you to be like all right
am i moving because this is what i want
to do
without him in my life in the next two
years if
your answer is yes you move and if he
offers you money i'ma say this
don't even accept it because what i
don't want you to do is to feel
pressured
that if something goes wrong down the
road that you owe him this money
or it creates a little salty flavor
between y'all two
i say move solely on your own in an
area that you can afford okay so ao is
absolutely 100
right taylor so the question is are you
moving because of him are you moving
because of your career and the big
vision you have
and tell it tell the truth we won't tell
them okay
oh um oh oh i'm absolutely moving
because of um i'm moving for myself i'm
moving for better opportunities i'm
moving for a better job
yes so he knows this okay now yeah all
right so we're done with that issue
you're not going to ask him or expect
him and you're not going to take it if
he offers so let's move on
i want to know you said you got a side
hustle yeah
i'm assuming that's going to dallas with
you is that the ultimate goal to get
that to a point where it replaces your
your current income or is that something
you just want to keep as a side hustle
no that's actually something i just want
to keep as a ride
uh all right next question because it's
not my own business
perfect okay good now my next question
is this job you're taking where you're
not making any money for a couple months
could you explain that to me real quick
yeah what kind of job is it okay okay
well um i cannot say the school district
so
basically it's a um alternative teacher
certification program
why aren't you getting paid for a couple
of months
well um the
program has different phases and so the
phase
where i say for a couple months but um
the phase where i would actually be paid
would be when i'm actually
in the classroom and so it could be a
month
okay i got it yeah i got it all right
just wanted to make sure that i
understood that and so that's going to
be a nice bump for you
correct yes okay do you have any debt
yes all right are you walking the baby
steps out
i am walking the baby steps out there we
go because i know you told me you're in
baby step two so you got to walk it out
this increase in pay
regardless of this dude right yeah
you're going to keep walking out as
anthony
said he's absolutely right this is a
move for you
and a move by you and then if once the
move
has been executed and you're there and
as anthony said he puts a ring on it he
steps up and you guys get married then
we combine everything we do keep we keep
everything separate until then ao final
word on this
nah man don't i mean it didn't great and
that was it
and if the guy's hearing us we're not
knocking you we're just trying to
protect both of you that's right that's
it
yeah good stuff all right taylor
congrats by the way
on the new job and moving forward in
your life
love love love that story all right
don't move
more of your calls coming up real soon
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
this is the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague
anthony o'neil and we're taking your
questions this hour triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five
two two five and uh big news
our famous ten dollar sale is happening
now you can learn how to make faster and
real progress with your money
when you check out our famous ten dollar
sale save up to sixty percent
on over 40 best-selling books and
budgeting tools like my colleague
anthony o'neill's
number one bestseller debt free degree
oh and my number one bestseller the
proximity principle
plus all of these books make for great
gifts for somebody who needs that
nudge maybe just giving them a book and
a recommendation
makes a trajectory change in their life
you can shop our 10 sale at our online
store
at ramseysolutions.com and that's not
all we've got a gift for you too
you can also enter to win our ramsey
cash giveaway
we're giving away 500 in cash every week
and a grand prize of five thousand
dollars cash
enter daily for extra chances to win no
purchase
necessary must be 18 or older to win the
cash text cash
seven 233 nine to enter our giveaway now
text cash
to three three seven eight nine
all right to the phones we go austin
texas is where emily joins us
emily how can we help hey
so i kind of have a financial slash
dating question um my question is how to
identify financial red flags when dating
someone um especially early on
i you know hindsight of course is 20 20
and
i recently you know found myself dating
someone
um who had their car declined a
couple times on you know really small
brunches and
was pulling out a lot of money from his
401k to
buy a house that was going to have an
unreasonable mortgage
and things like that and i kind of you
know
glazed over it and kind of like he'll
figure it out or whatever but in my head
i knew
there were poor decisions and something
not lining up right
um so i feel like i kind of spend a lot
more time
dating someone than i should um
when i when i am told these things and
find out this information i
should kind of be like okay you know
this isn't for me because this is
actively happening
and you think it's a good idea and i
don't you know and these are really big
decisions being made so how do i
identify and acknowledge
financial red flags
anthony are looking at each other going
who's going to go first on this um
well i think you've identified those red
flags don't you i mean they're just the
ones you gave us
uh are you saying that you didn't
identify them initially and now you're
aware of them is that what you're saying
yeah so in the moment i'm like i think i
kind of glaze over them
or maybe um like lesson watered them
down in my head just because i'm
personally you know on a
debt payoff journey no no no no
no no no let me tell you what's going on
so that's what i thought so you knew
those were red flags then
and you chose not to do anything about
them and that's a that's a relationship
thing that's a thing inside of you
that's an emotional thing inside of you
i'm not ready to tell you what that is
but i think that you
could probably tell us if you're honest
with yourself there's something
emotionally happening to you when you
see this and you go this is not
good this is completely opposite of what
i think about money
and i'm not going to say anything about
it just because i don't want to be
lonely or i don't want to be rejected i
don't know what is it
that's what i want to know what do you
think it is
um you know i think i kind of am
an over giver and i easily
feel bad for people so i'm kind of like
oh you know maybe i can just
help guide the way or you know give
advice along the way
i don't know i i start to think of how i
can maybe
overcompensate did you do that in that
past relationship i'm guessing this is
in the past correct
oh yes did you give it did you did you
teach did you
give advice and then how did he react
um yeah and i actually would bring up
like dave ramsey
and you know those steps and things and
how i'm following them
and i kind of got the shrug of the
shoulders and the kind of like
maybe i don't know about that and i even
got maybe one time
i don't think you should listen to that
guy so there's your sign
yeah and yeah so it's definitely in the
moment thing i don't know i'm
too nice yeah there is something it
could be a lonely
factor that you're talking about there
but i'm gonna i'm gonna
i want i want ao to jump in because he's
single and this is a guy who's very
public about his financial stances and
so
he runs into this way more i've been
married almost 23 years so
i i you know look i'm going to speak to
you almost like
maybe the uncle for a moment um i think
you're really clear on what the red
flags are and you identified them
and i actually don't mind you you know
you're dating a young man and
and uh he's doing things like that and
you go that's kind of not what i believe
at all that and then you go hey listen
i noticed this this and this don't
embarrass you
this is what i believe about money what
are your thoughts on money i mean i
think it's just as much of a relevant
topic is
what do you think about kids and what do
you think about uh religion and faith
these are all things that eventually you
got to talk about
anyway so i don't think you harp on it
but i think if you give
your opinion on it say hey i can help
you with this i can teach you how to
budget we can go to this class together
and if a dude's really invested in you
number one and number two healthy enough
to go
yeah i can acknowledge i don't know
anything about money and i'm just kind
of doing what i thought
then i'm fine with those red flags
because all of a sudden those become
caution flags yellow and then we could
turn those into green flags
that would be my take ayo but if if
they're making fun
of you and going you don't need to
listen to that guy then we have a clear
separation on values and that money
problem
will never go away yeah even if you get
married yeah yeah
and i'm so glad that you said that uh
ken emily
kim was going right where i was going i
wrote down
two things number one you need to
identify
what are your financial values uh that
you stand true to
and then while you're dating someone and
as you're getting to know
someone you need to see if you're
equally yolked in those areas all right
uh because here's the truth um our
ramsey tribe our ramsey way is different
from what culture is saying
so you gotta identify is this a red flag
or is it a yellow flag
there's a difference between someone who
is uneducated who needs
education like what kim was hinting to
uh then someone who just says you know
i have the education and i don't care
this is what i want to do
i want i want to rack up debt i want to
do this i want to do that
that is someone that you know if you
don't line up with those values you need
to separate yourself from
doesn't make them a bad person it just
makes them hey we're not equally yo
we're not going down the same direction
cool beans great but there are a lot of
people out there who are just
financially illiterate you know like you
said uh taking out the 401k
undergo um do a home yeah that just
means he needs education on why that's
not
acceptable you know swiping a credit
card to um
pay for dinner that that's just
unacceptable and so
you know i think when we are dating
number one we have to identify
our financial values the number two is
let's not
hold someone accountable and
automatically say these are huge red
flags and they're a horrible person
because they're just not as educated
just try exposing him to
your way of thinking and your way of
processing finances
and then if and over time if you see he
or she america whoever you're dating
do not line up with what you believe in
yeah you got to separate yourself you
know
um ken i'm single and i'm not do this
absolutely i've seen ao folks like being
in
serious relationships and then something
that is a big value issue
how much time do you give it i mean i i
give a little bit of time
and what is involved in that time within
the first 90 days i identify
okay hey listen do we have the same
values financially now again i'm 36 i'm
turning 37 i desire marriage
you know uh sooner than later i'm about
to turn 40. so my my value is a little
bit different but for me
my main thing is do we do we both agree
on avoiding debt
that's number one number two when do we
both agree on building wealth and and
leaving a legacy
uh those that's number two the number
three is do we really which
should be number one do we believe in
being a good steward and giving a ten
percent
if we don't if we don't agree on those
three things i cannot be
with her she's a great individual but
she's just not my great individual to be
my wife yeah bottom line yeah and we
don't have time to discuss is going to
break but i'm guessing you do that in
other areas of your life as well not
just the finances yeah absolutely here
are the key values yes
and look it stinks yes if you've got a
great relationship but
but you just go hey this is not gonna
have a long-term potential so you're out
right yeah i believe the word that he
uses he bounces
i like that that's uh that's positive
that's not a breakup i'm bouncing
i'm bouncing to the next i love that
well i'll kick rocks
all right don't move more ramsey show
coming right up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague anthony
o'neil
and we are taking your questions it's a
free call triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five
five two two five how about we stay in
nashville anthony and mark is up next
mark how can we help hey thanks guys
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up my question is
um so i wasn't financially smart with my
money previously so my credit score
obviously took a hit
upon finding dave ramsey and other
financial advisors
i'm working to build my credit score up
and things like that so i've been paying
off debts working two jobs doing what i
have to do
um filing my taxes
i underpaid in 2020. so now i'm
set with a bill for about four grand
with the irs
um because of the fact that i am still
rebuilding my credit
obviously i don't qualify for a bank
loan as of right now the only thing i
qualify for is like peer-to-peer lending
such as like upstart lending club things
such as that so i'm wondering what you
guys would recommend
should i just face the irs head on with
the penalties and fees that come with it
or should i go ahead and take out that
loan with a peer-to-peer lender
um and pay that off through them instead
um yeah man you know we're not going to
tell you to borrow any kind of money
uh no matter what the situation is
so let's walk through the process on how
do we um approach the irs here
uh with this i mean the four thousand
dollars is not a lot of money let's just
be honest
um you know uh but let's talk about this
what's your incoming year right now
uh currently my income is about 48 uh
with
both jobs included okay 48 000
a year all right cool being so here's
the first thing you need to do mark you
need to get with a
a tax pro that can make sure that you do
not have this situation next year
okay um i would love to see you break
even
um and maybe maybe cross the line oh
when you're getting back
maybe a hundred dollars two hundred
dollars uh but the thing here is we want
to see you cross
we break even uh to on my side you know
ken and i we kind of like to break even
maybe oh just a little bit
uh but uh for you breaking even and
maybe getting very minimal about so
that's the very first thing you need to
do is get with a tax pro
to make sure that you can go ahead and
file correctly on your w-2 forms that's
number one the number two
is what other kind of debt do you have
right now
um a half old goods that are that were
in collections that i've been paying off
auto loan total how much
um as of right now yeah uh
probably right at a thousand let's see
what i have left
you only have a thousand dollars left
total debt outside of this four thousand
dollars
oh i'm sorry uh that was just for the
collections part i apologize
um i have other things like auto loan
yeah we have two auto loans that we're
currently paying for
okay you said we you and your uh spouse
oh yeah my significant other okay cool
so is your is this the 48 000
combined income between the both of you
um
she is has not been working um she is
looking
but she hasn't found anything she just
recently lost her job
okay um within this last month so she's
in the process of kind of starting over
in front of something different
cool great she's got money that she's
put aside but you don't want to touch it
just in case we need it so that way we
have our emergency fund and i'm still
working
how much we don't want to touch us yet
how about how much do you all have say
besides because you said she
no how much do you two together have
saved
oh okay um save together probably right
around six
that's everything sold oh yeah um yeah
mark man listen
um the irs is something you do not want
to play with
if you have six thousand dollars in your
savings account right now
you need to pay the irs off as soon as
you hang up the phone from ken and i
okay uh uh borrowing money from peer to
peer
horrible decision horrible thought um
going to them
and and paying fees and taxes not taxes
but fees and penalties
i'm on that because you don't you want
to keep six thousand dollars in your
savings account
horrible horrible decision what i would
do is i would take four thousand of that
right now and i will go pay the irs off
you have two thousand dollars left in
your account and then honestly bro i'll
take a thousand that put it towards my
current debt right now
it's really start eliminating your debt
as much as possible
and then from the on the flip side your
wife needs to get on the phone with ken
next week on his show
and let him walk your way through on how
to land a job to get y'all's income
up yeah that's right this economy and
certainly in the nashville area
there are jobs all over the place and i
don't even care
if it's a job she likes you know at this
point we are going to get her employed
and start knocking out the rest of those
auto loans and then you guys are
rocking your way through the baby steps
but you got to pay the irs off now
yeah man you guys don't need the 6 000.
you're fine
she could go deliver pizzas and and do
whatever
right now but pay the irs off
immediately do you understand what we're
saying
yes sir i do appreciate it all right
well we're putting you on hold
so you can uh talk to your wife call the
irs
yeah goodness here's the money right now
can i can i can i do direct deposit on
this you know
you know it's like boom here it is i'm
going to be free of the irs
they're not going away oh no and the
last thing you do is you want you don't
want them calling you a job you don't
want them garnishing your wages you
don't want them pulling money from your
account
all because you're trying to keep the
money in your account
it's ridiculous it's not worth it pay
the irs
good good advice there all right let's
go now to chase who joins us
in tampa florida chase how can we help
hey how we doing guys
we're living the dream what's up
uh same here actually i'm working remote
at the moment
i tried starting a company but it it
failed because of covid i won't get into
that i won't bore you guys in the
details
just just about finishing off paying off
the debt that i incurred from that
and i just i'm about also to finish
getting out of a rental situation here
so
i don't want to buy a house where i'm at
and i don't want to go sign a lease
somewhere else
in the country while i decide do i like
this area enough to invest in or not
plus i feel like the housing market is
insanely fuego right now
so my my question and what i was
thinking about doing was
i know this is not an investment this
contemporary was to buy
a because i already had a paid off truck
to buy a really cheap used trailer
and sort of you know live close to the
earth drive around the country
kind of save money so like i said i work
remote and
figure out where in this country should
be like the next place i invest and kind
of
kind of get to does that make financial
sense to you guys
well we need more more of the picture
what kind of debt do you have what's
your total debt left to pay off
uh just about 8 000 now and and so this
would be your list are you living
are you paying rent or own a home right
now or not
no uh when this whole when i try to
start the business and it failed um
a buddy of mine owns a home so i started
renting a room from him
okay what are you what's your income
right now what's your net each month
net uh just about 10 000.
how much is the trailer going to cost
i'm assuming you looked into it and
you're gonna hitch it up to that big old
paid for truck
yes sir uh yeah so i was thinking about
going to super super cheap route
and either buying an enclosed trailer
and just kind of putting a bed in a hit
believe it or not yeah coming out a
little bit okay 10 grand
10 grand for a trailer yes sir and
you've got that cash ready to go
no no so i would be i would be safe
paying off finishing paying off my
credit cards
saving that cash and then buying it and
then figuring out because
with the amount of money i'm making i
just i don't want to
purchase a home where i feel like it's
way overvalued here my friend's home
he's in right now he bought it five
years ago for 200 was just appraised for
just shy for no
i get it i get it you don't you don't
have to explain that i just wanted to
make sure so yeah i would not purchase
this i'm fine with it if you pay your
debt off first
you're living in somebody's home for
free right now so yeah knock out your
debt
and uh and yeah i'm fine with that
that's your home and you're making good
income
uh your net you know if save up for it
pay cash
and that's your home for however many
months and then my guess is you're gonna
get a good chunk of that back
is that right on those trailers no uh no
doubt it yeah
oh really trailers okay to show you what
i know about trailers which i do nothing
for 10k i'm either going to be buying
something from the 80s or the 90s that's
bank up the hill
yeah or i'll be buying an enclosed
trailer new and like i said
putting a pre-made bathroom and a bed in
it all right so here's the deal if you
pay cash for it
and that's what you're living in you're
man you're you're set you're stacking
money
hey yo i'm fine with that until he
figures out where he wants to go
i'm cool with it i would look into an
apartment i'm not a fan of trailers
yeah but he wants to drive around the
country and figure out where he's going
to live cool
great that's the only reason we're cool
with that yeah because he's like he's
kind of like checking it all out
all right very interesting i don't know
that trailer may want to
make him want to get an apartment pretty
quick it made me want to get an
apartment today
all right don't move more of your calls
coming up this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
i'm joined in studio by my colleague
anthony o'neal
and our scripture verse of the day comes
from proverbs
16 24. gracious words are a honeycomb
sweet to the soul and healing to the
bones our quote
from apple founder steve jobs the only
way to do great work is to love what you
do
if you haven't found it yet keep looking
don't settle amen and
amen triple eight eight two five five
two two five
is the phone number triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
phoenix arizona
where kelly joins us kelly how can we
help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
i really love all the advice that you
give
i'm i'm a single mother i'm about 47
i'm i've just recently been certified to
teach but i also have a daughter with
autism
um i have three children
one of my children died in the care of
her father about
12 years ago and um i spent a hundred
thousand dollars in here
just keeping my kids safe you know
keeping supervised visitation in place
and i wanted to know i'm trying to get
back into the classroom
but it's hard for me with a child with
autism and being a first-year teacher
it's just a lot of take-home work and it
doesn't allow me to
properly you know facilitate her
services or spend time with her
but i have some assets i think i have i
have a 401k
i also have a um a quadro
i have about fifteen thousand dollars in
quadro as that i don't have a home or
anything i'm living
i've had to live with family for a while
just because of the situation
but i wanted to know what the best thing
that i can do with my money to be set up
for retirement
okay say that last party the best thing
to do with your money what you broke up
oh i'm sorry i'm so sorry i just wanted
to know what the best thing i can do
with my assets
i'd have to keep my assets fluid in case
i was litigating
but i'm not litigating anymore so i
wanted to know what the best thing
to do to prepare for retirement of
course my assets would be
yeah yeah that's such a good question so
um and sorry again
your phone was going in and out how much
money do you have again
in all i'm trying to hear it clearly i'm
gonna make sure i have the correct
number
and i'm sorry about that um i have about
i think i have about seventy thousand
dollars in a 401k
okay i have fifteen thousand dollars at
vanguard in the quadro
and then i've saved my stimulus money
and my tax return
i do have a car but i have enough to pay
it off okay and i have about
i want to say i have about fifteen
thousand dollars in cash fifteen
thousand dollars in cash all right
how old are you 40 48
48 okay cool and you're trying to figure
out retirement right like how do you set
yourself up to better win with
retirement
yeah because i'm i'm also i'm trying to
get into the
workforce i i'm very hirable as a
teacher
but the time constraints don't allow me
to be a mother so it's
it's i'm looking for a job as well okay
so we got two things there so ao you
want to take on the retirement and then
we can we can talk to
or how do you want to do this yeah we
got to cover the job first because i
think
i can't really talk about that yeah so
okay so here's the deal
um you're qualified to be a teacher and
you want to be in the classroom but
because of the autism
with your child uh you're saying i can't
be in the classroom because i don't have
anyone else to care
for the child is that what i'm hearing
yeah
there's a lot of there's about 20 i've
been taking home i i taught for
like three months and the pandemic made
it crazy but yeah it was just a lot of
stuff to take home as a first year
teacher
i used to preview everything i have to
leave timely comments i just got all the
things
it is just a lot okay so what you're
saying is it's not that okay so it's not
the child care issue during the day
it's it's that i'm not going to be able
to keep up with the work because of what
i got to be as a mom when i come home
that's what you're concerned exactly yes
okay well
but the reality is you got to work yeah
and and now you've got some independence
feels like from this whole
nasty unbelievably difficult situation
and i'm so
sorry i am so sorry you've been through
this
but um
i on one hand i want to tell you that i
believe you can do this
i believe that you can be a mom
i believe that you can get some help at
night or whatever
but i also understand that you're way
more familiar with your situation than i
am as far as
what kind of impact that's going to have
on you but if you're not going to be
able to teach in the classroom then
you're going to have to go get what i
would call a day job
and because of that certification and
that training and all of the skill set
that you have as a teacher
you know if you can get a job for a
while
to uh to to kind of take care of the
finances and get stable and then you get
you can get on an investment strategy
and we're going to connect you to
a smart investor pro out there in your
area that can sit down with you
and really go okay here's all the
different assets let's get a strategy
for you
but from a full-time standpoint if you
want to teach
at some point you're going to have to
jump in is
is where i'm coming at this i want to be
very sensitive to what you're saying
but at some point either you do it now
or five years from now then you go into
teaching
but if you want to teach you're gonna
eventually regret this if you don't get
into the classroom and do it now i
am i hear from teachers all the time on
the ken coleman show
that are feeling burned out because all
the paperwork i'm not minimizing that at
all
i just think you have to decide what's
best
for me right now and if it's well i
really don't think i could be a first
year teacher
right now is that going to change in
three to four years or five years with
your child or no
um yes it probably will she's she's 10
and she's um you know her hormones are
kicking in so it's a little
bit it should change but i am substitute
teaching
so i do have income coming in do you
have a family around you
i i do let me ask you this what
have you talked i mean you've done some
research because you're worried about
all of the paperwork coming home so
you've talked to somebody you've got a
pretty good idea on this
have you taken this to family to say hey
i'm very hireable i got an opportunity
to get in here
but based on what other teachers are
telling me in my first year i'm gonna
have a ton of this
and i'm a little bit worried how it's
gonna affect me and my mom duties
can you help have you had that
conversation
you know i have my parents are between
75 and 80 years old and
the behaviors that um and my daughter is
precious but her behaviors are a little
bit much for them i guess
and she also has services so i'm and i'm
sorry if we're going a little bit long
oh it's fine no i i think but i'm also
looking for i
i'm i am substitute teaching right now
and if even if i had to wait five years
i still am looking for something um
you know i worked in that transition
from school to work program so there's
kids with disabilities there something
has a really good reputation of dealing
with yeah that's what i was going to ask
you
i i i would like you to consider and do
some research
on other jobs that are non-teacher jobs
but in the education system so it's what
i would call the proximity principle
right
you you're in and around people that are
teaching you're staying active so if it
is a three to five year deal that you
got to kind of put this off
until you're a different season at least
you're working
in the school system i like that move
and that certification and training you
have
also makes it relevant they say why
aren't you applying to be a teacher you
go because this is my situation with my
daughter
but i want to be in the education system
so therefore
it takes care of the steady income keeps
you in the education
space so it keeps those connections
vibrant and so the moment that you feel
like your daughter's turned a corner or
that you can kind of get in the
classroom
and deal with that onslaught of stress
in the first year you've got all the
connections necessary does that make
sense
it definitely does that's where i would
go there's a lot of
non-teacher positions
i worked as a teacher's aide for a long
time but it only pays about 12
an hour well i know but so now that's
where we go okay wait a second we can't
do that
but right now you're just doing
substitute teaching which isn't paying
that great
so i'm saying like you're working in the
maybe the district school
office there's a school board maybe
you're working um
you know again in the in the office so
you're maybe you're you know a teacher
aide plus a receptionist plus plus plus
if you dive into this and figure out
how i can work 40 hours a week in the
school system
i'm telling you you'll get it and that's
what you've got to do and then it takes
that pressure off but you've not
completely
removed yourself from the field that you
want to be in you know let me just say
this i mean you you
you've had a quite a journey yeah and
you can feel the pressure still on you
and i want to make sure that you're
taking care of yourself
here in this time the the the strength
that kelly that you have exhibited is
it's it's um it's indescribable to me
ayo
what she's gone through losing a child
all kinds of legal battles
uh you know the the challenges with her
beautiful daughter
that's a lot yeah and this isn't just a
a kelly you can do this
thing this is you got to make sure you
take care of yourself in this
as well so that you don't flame out but
you'll get there
i would stay in the education field wow
unbelievable hey heyo
always good to hang with you brother
appreciate you so much i want to say
thanks to james childs our producer
our associate producer and call speaker
kelly daniel
but most of all you america thank you
for joining us this has been the ramsay
show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsay call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you